this week the BBC and the Guardian have
finally discovered why Switzerland is
the best place to hide money apparently
that's what the holes and the cheese is
for up until the late naughties hsbc
britain's biggest bank knowingly helped
its clients break the law and actually
marketed tax evading services to its
wealthiest customers now the problem
with secret money is that in order to
keep it secret you actually have to deal
in cold hard cash in Switzerland and
that means going in person to Geneva and
no one actually really wants to do that
it's it's kind of boring that place it's
it's the camber of the North HSBC
assisted one British client who
collected seventy thousand pounds in
cash a year and insisted that it all be
in discreet
low denominations now clearly this
person had a high-end stripper addiction
instead of making it rain just wanted to
make it poor one Chloe
HSBC manager in Paris offered wealthy
clients untraceable cash by first
putting it through the bank accounts of
France's biggest drug lords the juice we
methamphetamine in 2010 a US client was
given bricks of a hundred thousand
dollars each which he then split up in
two fistfuls of cash and then mailed
back to himself in the u.s. such hard
work to avoid all this tax I don't know
what's worse paying tax or go to the
post office there's pet attacks but
probably my favorite tax dodging serves
from HSBC is the codename if you're
famous are rich enough they'll create
one for you for free like the former
chairman of the answered Bank Charles
good HSBC suggested that mr. good was a
little too conspicuous so they gave him
the code name please be deep throat
please be deep throat of mr. Shaw more
like mr. offshore to me I don't know
about you but if I'm holding hundreds
and thousands of dollars of tax three
money in a Swiss bank account at least I
would have gone from mr. good to mr. bad
I mean at the very most I would have
demanded HSBC called me mr. McDuck
this is not the first time that HSBC has
been in the news for helping other bad
guys in 2012 the bank was forced to pay
two billion dollars in fines in the US
for helping drug cartels in Colombia and
Mexico shift their money around the
world so big with a cash trans
actions of the cartels that the bank
teller windows in Mexico and Russia had
to be enlarged and to fit the cash boxes
over the counter Wow
HSBC you play a bold game France Belgium
Argentina the US they've all started to
prosecute people involved in these
schemes but in the home country of HSBC
Great Britain only one person has been
prosecuted one person out of thousands
of accounts now maybe we should give
that UK government a bit of a break
after all did happen in Switzerland they
weren't meant to know what's happening
in HSBC excuse me hello what Oh the
former chief executive and chairman of
HSBC Lord Stephen green was appointed
appear in the House of Lords then made
Minister for Trade and Investment in the
Cameron government oh but that's
ridiculous I mean surely he'd know heaps
of people to prosecute I'm sure many of
those people like his friends you know
what making Lord Stephen green the
Minister of investment is like making
Michael Jackson the manager of a daycare
center we wanted to ask why his bank
helps the wealthy evade tax he wrote to
us and said as a matter of principle I
will not comment on the business of HSBC
past or present yes Stephen green is
very principled he's number one
principle not going to jail but that
didn't stop bbc's panorama from trying
to ask him the tough questions no when
you were in charge HSBC no comment your
bankers were helping people dodge tax
why did you let them do that as I think
I've explained I'm not prepared to make
any comments on HSBC's business parts or
presence oh come on baby say give the
man a break can't you see he's so poor
as to walk home from work he can't
afford a car well maybe it's just a case
of taxi avoidance to afford a car what
he should have done is take up one of
HSBC's tax avoidance schemes life is all
about perspective you see a tropical
holiday we see a business meeting you
see your grandmother we see your
inheritance you see a kilo of coke we
see a liquid asset you see a tax bill we
don't see anything
you see a jail we see record profit what
do you see with HSBC
you